female mate selection definitely has an
impact on the overall you know sort of
statistical distribution of male
attributes and strength and power and
all these things
and uh i you know dude i am very
sympathetic to this argument about
dating apps uh as as a tall handsome
smart successful guy i certainly saw the
other side of that don't criticize
yourself that way
that's perspective and modest don't be
that modest but but i will i will point
out though that those trends were
actually in place long before the apps
came along the declining fertility rate
decline and marriage rates increase in
marriage age etc were well in place
before those apps came about it has
exacerbated it and of course as someone
where here we're talking about the way
twitter and youtube and algorithms
change change and shape the dialogue and
our politics and out what we think about
each other of course the same kind of
algorithms are at work in these dating
apps and are affecting the mating dating
and mating markets and frankly uh it was
my analysis and exploration into that
phenomenon which has gotten me to where
i am now 10 years later after my divorce
in 2009 pulling on the same threads
trying to figure this stuff out and here
we are talking about these big meta
issues safety
is in my opinion the number one issue
that is driving a lot of those of those
things getting married later on you know
so so so you mentioned protecting and
providing is like a masculine role
versus what was the other one nurturing
caring nurturing and caring is like the
more feminine role and it used to be
back in the day that you had a parent to
watch the kids times change for a
variety of reasons but ultimately i
think it has to do with the sphere of
safety that we've created and you can
take a look at how that manifests now in
the modern era with safe spaces with
censorship with offense culture and
victim culture we have become so
incredibly safe that people have become
soft wads of cookie dough that are
terrified and and victimized by stubbing
their toe i remember in this this sorry
just ultimately this this selects for
the the biological success of historic
of people who historically would not
likely be
in school i mean think of elementary
school on the playground girls and boys
playing this is like my personal
experience i remember seeing this stuff
a boy would make fun of another boy and
start talking him down and saying you're
terrible you're blah and then other boys
would start to laugh and stand around
and then the girls would flock to the
kid that was making fun of the other kid
as if he was becoming the protector of
the the ho the herd and they're like
this guy
because of through his mean hierarchy or
whatever he's doing is now creating a
safe place for me to raise like he's
going to protect us from he's going to
demean others to grow his strength and
that's like
deeply ingrained in what i am i i think
that's just part of the hierarchy of
being animal and now they're trying to
algorize that out and
algorithes that's a new one for me look
there's look
there's two things happening here one
most men i believe it might be most or
at least close to a majority of men over
time have not reproduced
and socially enforced monogamy is a way
to solve for that problem then add in no
fault divorce
and discouraging women from you know
seeking out men who are protectors and
providers and becoming protectors and
providers themselves is exacerbating
this problem but it's also given us this
contrast where we've moved out of this
socially enforced monogamy into back the
wild west the state of nature when it
comes to mating and of course
not all guys are going to reproduce at
this point there's going to be a lot of
guys left out socially enforced monogamy
was a way to bring men into society to
give them a reason to live a reason to
build and create well that's interesting
so uh i think you're right and i think
if we combine these ideas basically
there was a period where you typically
wouldn't see
you know weaker men as successful as as
you would i mean physically right and
and in fact in many instances mentally
because life was a lot harder and people
didn't survive conflict and if you
couldn't make it but now these people
are doing well really well but you make
a good point they're also struggling on
dating apps
the age of a male who is a virgin is
getting higher and higher meaning i
think the last data was a few years ago
washington post released a study that
men under 30 were like a third of them
were virgins and so what we're seeing
now with dating apps is that it's
typically a small handful of men getting
all of the women which is like a
reversion back to the state of nature in
nature and i think resources don't
matter as much as they did before
especially in this ever-changing
landscape that is more influenced by
social media and hollywood and i think a
perfect representation of that is mr
bill gates if you look at mr bill gates
there's stories and accusations of him
having a very hard time getting women at
his own company so if you're talking
about one of the richest people in the
world at the time even having that kind
of trouble uh you know going off hanging
and partying with epstein but that's
another story there but but but the man
with all the resources is having a hard
time even even getting uh a girlfriend
uh at microsoft so
sure and there's a bunch of microsoft
jokes we can make here
i am above that
uh i'm above that
not really but at the rest stop
but but it is it is an ever-changing
economy that is very interesting that i
think is still changing and it's very
hard to kind of classify even what's
going on we are in a crazy state of
change we are between two fixed points
we are in what we call a liminal period
right we had a very fixed circumstance
you had culturally enforced monogamy no
fault divorce everybody gets married
everybody has a couple kids everybody
works that has dissipated we're now back
into a new sort of explosion we don't
know or implosion and we don't know
where it's going to settle it's not
looking good for the average guy and
what happens when the average guy
is disgruntled and then there's a lot of
them and i think china is facing that
basically look you know looking down the
barrel with that you know traditionally
what do you do with your surplus men you
send them off to war right and they have
a lot of surplus men in china they have
a huge uh population despair g where
where literally this is
good thing we're not on tv i speak
multiple languages okay uh
english was not my first language
doesn't matter oh
i guess okay now you're making fun of a
minority yeah i'm a person of color
according to the person
exactly so you better watch out jack
there's men literally
competing for women on the streets in in
some cities in china trying to get one
date with one girl and they have entire
competitions where their entire town
comes out to see which man will get to
date this single woman so
on that kind of level this is all
because of the kind of eugenics
population could control agenda that
rockefeller and ted turner pushed and
promoted with china that made them have
one child policy that prioritized
specifically males being born and a lot
of baby girls were either aborted or
terminated or smuggled out of the
country because culturally
in china the male takes care of the
family and if you have a female and if
you're only allowed one child you're not
going to have someone that will take
care of you so that made a huge i mean
the rockefeller policy uh on china the
one child policy was absolutely uh you
know
horrible to say when you combine that
effect in china with in their history of
like sending men to war with like spoons
butter knives and sticks up against guys
with machine guns they're doing that in
pakistan that's what i'm saying dude the
chinese i think i might be wrong on this
but in the korean war i do believe
they've stormed over the border with
nothing but like sticks and spoons and
butter knives and they went to fight in
battle like that they are willing to do
whatever they they can and if you're
going to have surplus men in an
imperialist environment with aspirations
for growth and dominance i mean that's a
that's an interesting situation for
taiwan well for especially during a weak
presidency that literally does the
opposite of what he's supposed to do
during military conflict like he did in
afghanistan so so are we looking at
you know we talk about through cities
trap we talk about just china's as a
growing military power but is the real
reason war breaks out is because china
looks at the us and says we got too many
dudes if we're stuck under they're
frustrated thunderdome if we're stuck on
all in well it's not too many it's just
like hey look what do we have to work
with here oh look at that we got all
these dudes what could we do with them
they're useful space travel that's the
thing if we're stuck in uh
this is why it's on the show this is my
behavior and this is the reason
behavioral sync went the way it did is
because they couldn't spread out they
were stuck in an enclosed space like we
are on earth and if we keep growing like
we're growing and we're still stuck here
either these people that want to
slow the population growth or war i
think are the two inevitable um people
have been making this argument space
travel
mars yeah let's start experiencing
although now imperial you have to do
that right you just like a slingshot
from down here you can get a magnetic
slingshot and then another reverse
magnetic slingshot in the martian orbit
so they cut it slows it down and catches
it and then sends it down on an elevator
with a graphing tether to uh
somebody from the outer rim comes and
destroys it i've been watching that show
on apple i read the books what if the
policy was in instead of the one child
policy it was the one child two second
one child second astronaut policy so
after your first kill tomorrow the
second kid was was going to go in the
astronaut program and we're like we got
a kid send them to mars colonize amazing
dude they're raised in space you send
your second kid up into orbit to have
them be raised
like 100 million dollars to send
somebody into space you don't want it to
be like the knucklehead of your family
that didn't have anything that's the
problem is it's too expensive that's why
the space elevator is fascinating yeah
it's too expensive rocketry there's two
ways you can look at it quantity or qual
quality and quality would be like let's
get 10 great astronauts and send them up
there to build this or you can be like
or a hundred dumb ones
and like if each of them only does ten
percent output
you know
they won't
if they make it a week they make it
but you know you send enough of them up
there and they're going to colonize
by the way i am never going into space
i'm not either ever never ever what
about orbit i might do what uh shatner
just did yeah but i'm definitely not
going to mars i'm definitely not going
out there and being trapped in a tin can
in the middle of a cold dark with the
current no uh with the current setup
like with the current uh environment
right if it was like tom swift's style
where it was like a rotating cylinder
like elysium right where it's like this
amazing earth-like atmosphere with like
trees and plants and lakes and stuff
maybe then you diva
what about on a spaceship in orbit just
to float for a while no no no hold on
there man hold on
for that let me ask you something though
so uh the colonists who were who are
leaving the comfort of their of their
countries where they had you know a
system in place an economy said i'm
gonna get on this boat
it's gonna take me three months to maybe
get to a place i've never seen before
but people tell me it sounds good a lot
of people
are gonna die on the boat from various
illnesses diseases scurvy is going to
affect them really bad and then if they
make it they're landing on the shore
where there's nothing right barren land
and they are like yo sounds good right
well a how bad was life
b
that's but that's like the promise of a
potential paradise and don't forget that
many of the people that made that
journey were looking for a new zion they
were american zionists looking to create
god's paradise on earth and they weren't
going to do it in established civilized
europe they had to go do it in the
wilderness of north america now look
dude if you're trying to tell me that
like i understand that the process of
being in a spaceship going to mars
terrible the process of being on a boat
sailing to the new world also terrible
landing on mars terrible landing in the
new world huh paradise everything you
want
what was paradise about it there were
animals and trees and lakes and rivers
and resources and food i mean i know
they didn't figure it out right away but
there's plenty of food and game and all
these things and a huge expanse uh yeah
no space red dust voids vacuums they're
they're i think they're just people that
uh got the explorer bug totes i think i
think there's a lot on the on the planet
we need to explore well a lot of people
were facing religious persecution yeah
and and that's why a lot of them left
you under you got to understand you're
all the trump supporters
mars mars yeah there was plagues there
was diseases there was war there was
there was there was lack of food
so anything other than that was was was
better for a lot of people that's why
they took the risk of going overseas and
think about it too once it was
established here why do people immigrate
to united states
because it's better
immigrating to mars is worse but this is
what bugs me
have you been to mars
let me let me tell you i saw i saw that
uh totally when i when i was like 18
i mean we got to be hard again listen
when i was like 18 we had hard winters
in chicago so you can't skate very much
in the winter it sucks that means
everybody knows like you get rusty you
get tired you get out of shape and so we
knew some people who had a private
warehouse with a mini ramp and a skate
on and i was like guys we need to do
this too we need to have our own indoor
space if we all pitch in 100 bucks right
now we got it tim the original communist
you know what they they all said to me
do it and then once you have it i'll
think about joining and i said the only
way we get it is if we work together
right now to do it and they said nah and
then they did nothing all winter and sat
around just getting fat and lazy
i can't i can't i can't stand that yo if
you if you want to find a new place or a
new world i'm saying i'm not saying it's
you i'm saying for the people who do you
can go to mars and put in the work don't
expect someone else
with immigration yeah they all want to
come here now because a bunch of people
risked life and limb to cross a notion
many i think it was like 20 people on
boats died they finally get here and
there was conflict and there was crisis
and there was some bad bs that went down
a lot of it mind you and then they built
a civilization and now it's so beautiful
everybody's like i want to go there and
i'm gonna and screw their laws through
their roles i'm gonna go take whatever i
want now do the work put in the work
earn your keep help keep the system that
you want so badly to keep functioning
tim uh universal health care right here
earn your keepers i'm absolutely this is
this is this is the thing i i'm totally
for universal health care but not the
way bernie sanders wants to do it yeah
and the other problem is you get a
government that has control over your
health care and then all of a sudden
they're doing vaccines by race right
which is what they tried doing right so
anyway i digress yeah i think
people should be explorers maybe
pioneers we can resettle the american
interior there is so much to do there
there's so many places let's go settle
alaska yes and i think at this point
it's not only
cool but like inevitably necessary if we
want to avoid war to expand into space i
know it seems like a daunting task to
terraform mars but we can do it we could
terraform we could add set up
civilizations on the moon you know there
are ways if you if you really take time
out of the equation
we have to send massive cargo payloads
so just for over over the span of
several years so that when we finally
send the first team they show up with
like 20 years worth of food and fuel and
building materials and then they can
build biospheres and domes and stuff
like that but ultimately i'm not i'm not
convinced mars colonization is a real
thing i don't think so either by the
time by the time we can terraform mars
we could just fix any climate issues
here terraform whatever yeah yeah we'll
be terraforming all mars has no
magnetosphere no matter it has a weak
one so it means that i can't use my
compass sorry it looks like this means
you'll get bombarded by radiation and
solar particles and then you'll just
again this is why no one has gone past
the van allen the van what is it van
allen belt the van allen no i don't
think that's true so we went to the moon
did we though just kidding are we
allowed to say that maybe i don't know
about that crap i'm just kidding
stanley kubrick didn't make a art about
it as well but apparently we did go to
the moon too yeah but why haven't we
been back dawg i think it's just
expensive just not getting anything out
of it yeah this one's always crazy to me
it's like how did we get to the moon
dude we literally built a rocket we had
we have tons of rockets rockets are not
hard and then you just do basic math for
like how to get there why haven't we
gone back because we didn't get anything
from doing it other than wagging our
finger at russians
we don't have them there's a lot of
military capabilities on being on the
moon
sure sure and china's looking at going
back on the moon to launch military
installations there so i'm with jack on
this one i agree oh my god i can't
believe this is happening high five
we actually agreed on something
probably underground you'll want to
colonize on the moon yeah so you can
avoid that like make it a death star
like build a gigantic ion you know
cannon or
laser beam
it looks like the crater that looks like
a small moon it looked like marsh on
mars was ripped open at some point
there's a big scar in that a bunch of
its core came out onto the surface and
then all that iron core came down as
iron oxide dust so you have all that red
dust and that's why the magnetosphere
has been weakened because it's missing a
lot of that iron that was in the middle
so we've either reintroduced the iron
into the core or try and i don't know
you know i think we can nuke the cores
and jump start them what they say about
real estate location locations locations
mars sounds like a terrible people that
came to the us first are the now the the
great ancestors of the land owners and
all these rich people right right so so
actually i think this is the look we can
talk all day about iron oxide and cores
and all that stuff but i think the real
issue that i wanted to bring up is is
that is that pioneer spirit still within
our hearts yeah i think i think it is
and you find it in the entrepreneurial
spirit in the united
in st you know they had a big city that
universities they had science and math
and industry bezos and musk are a good
example of no but where where are the
people uh
james cameron james cameron with the
submarine and all that that's right i'm
talking about building cities yeah like
all we have are cities in decay where is
anyone to be like i have just bought
land and i have staked my claim and now
i think there's i think that i think
that happens
in texas yeah do you guys see that that
company that wants to do the weird city
of like leftists utopia whatever no i
haven't we got we got how are you going
to criticize the lack of the pioneer
spirit and the first example someone
gives you you're like those weirdos
no you got to celebrate them
i'll tell you this if all the woke
people want to go into their own private
city like yeah it's fantastic yeah they
have it it's called washington d.c
we just sealed the deal on on for
damasteen oh there you go officially
and we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna
put up our little street names and we're
gonna start building stuff out and just
you know we want to get an ffl luke's
adamant about you know a thousand yard
range we're not going to do that
come on
we can but i think we shouldn't
it's extremely difficult considering
like we're not in the middle of nowhere
nowhere it's a big property but if we're
going to be setting up free damastan
meaning we gotta have a lot of
facilities and buildings then i don't
think we can allocate you know nothing
else nothing's impossible it looks like
the chinese are building on
time and money we'll figure it out
building islands as well well i'll tell
you this colonization is happening and
it's china and it's and it's happening
for a lot of the same reasons it's
overcrowded people want to find a better
place to live so a lot of chinese
citizens are are going out to other
countries and
setting up and
expanding so i i i i think we were
talking about this with africa with
south america we talked about it quite a
bit it's not like a militaristic uh
operation it's just literally someone in
china being like it's crowded i want
work hey here's an opportunity there's a
company that's hiring in this country
that's building bridges or or selling
oil or something so they move out there
with their families and then you end up
getting these pockets of chinese
nationals living in all these other
places i remember testimony to the
american power where people aren't
trying sorry people aren't doing that i
remember being here in kenya zimbabwe
and somalia and i was astonished at how
many chinese people i saw all over the
place running around there and i had a
lot of local africans being like this is
this is the new wave of imperialism they
are the new colonizers the chinese have
come in and they're taking over uh
resources they're taking over
infrastructure and they're also building
a lot of infrastructure there so ports
and harbors all over the place by the
way some of the best chinese food i ever
had was in ecuador what do you know
but what kind of chinese food was it
szechuan was it like it was like real
like you know like diced chicken with
rice or whatever and spices i've never
been to china except for hong kong so i
can't really tell you but uh it was
pretty good i had a i i got a funny life
lesson for people you know what uh i
went to thailand
and i'm with uh this guy i was working
with vice and he i was like i want to
eat real thai food and he was like oh
you want to eat real thai food right and
i was like yeah yeah real stuff none of
that americanized heavily sugared and
fat stuff is like you want to eat like
the real thai people like yes he's like
come with me and we go down to this
little uh there's like a little like
corner of a of a building on a block
like a residential area and they've got
these big shutters that have been open
and there's a little kitchen looks like
a regular old kitchen and i walk in and
he orders and tie and you know they come
out with
chicken steamed chicken and rice yeah
that's it literally just steamed chicken
and rice and i started laughing and he's
like what do you think people eat like
americans are so spoiled everything's
got sugar fat salt spices regular people
around the world they're eating rice and
meat
in in south america there's a saying
that they have rice and beans for lunch
and beans and rice for dinner
i noticed that when i was down there
chicken i went to brazil beans basically
i said the same thing to uh to my
brazilian friend i was like i'm gonna
eat like a real brazilian and he's like
all right and we went
and it was just it was just steak they
give you they give you like two steaks
and then everyone sits around it and you
cut them and you take it with rice but
there is one thing they do they sprinkle
cornmeal on top oh that was different i
think you're what you're also arguing is
just how what a wonderful bounty of
authentic food that we have here in the
united states thai food is it's like
yeah it's very i mean dude you can get
uh papaya salad in thailand on the
street which is one of my favorites i
love sticky rice on the street yeah well
and then you can you just get it right
here in the united states too i was in
thailand too man i ate street food all
the time but what i mean is like the
these like these are like specialty
meals that we think of they're like
oh like faux like a like yeah when you
go to these countries for the most part
regular food is just regular food it's
not you know it's not some fancy like i
was like i'm a pod thai and he's like
okay you know it's kind of what's
regular american food dude
meatloaf and mashed potatoes yeah
instant mashed potatoes instant mashed
potatoes i think i think
peas and steak with mashed potato peas
in a steak or something murder burger i
don't know anybody who eats peas
really that was my favorite food is it
peas they sell them at stores i just
died there's
i care not for the people oh they're a
little sweet
cancel me now it's good for babies do
you guys remember that new york times
article where they said mixed peas into
your guacamole and then there was like a
revolt where the left and the right came
together like with that fist meme like
no i try it sounds not bad that sounds
terrible murder are you a vegan hell no
well that's crazy i don't understand
what you meant by the murder murder okay
the mickey dudes oh yeah well i don't
even know what we're talking about
anymore basically pakistan pakistan is
up on the map up there okay yeah we're
talking about mcdonald's in ecuador you
mentioned world war iii you mentioned
china sending in their men to go fight
with sticks and stones they literally
did that they did that yeah um
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time